RONALD SMITH: Well,
I'm talking about storms, but
someone asked me a question the
other day about why the
Coriolis force is opposite
in the two hemispheres.
And I can't give you a complete
explanation, but I
can give you a partial
explanation.
Here's the globe, and of course,
it spins toward the
east. The sun rises in the east,
sets in the west. So
that's the way the
Earth spins.
If I keep spinning it in that
direction and I face this
towards you, is that clockwise
or counterclockwise?
Counterclockwise.
I'm going to keep spinning
it in that direction.
Is that clockwise or
counterclockwise?
Clockwise.
So in a sense, while the globe
spins eastward, the sense of
rotation is opposite in
the two hemispheres.
And that is one way to
understand why the Coriolis
force is opposite in the
two hemispheres.
So like I said, not a complete
explanation, but it's true,
and I think it helps to
understand that tricky point
about the Coriolis force.
Any questions on that?
So we're going through
storms today.
This is not very quantitative
material.
This stuff will be posted
after the fact, and your
textbook is very good.
These chapters that I've
assigned, a number of them
have to do with storm
types and so on.
So you'll find a good-- of
course, I will explain things
somewhat differently, but you'll
find a good way to get
competing views of this by
listening to what I say and
then reading the textbook, and
between the two, you should
come out pretty well
on this subject.
So we were talking about
convective storms. And that is
the class of storms that get
their energy from the release
of latent heat.
I mentioned this last time.
That's a number that I carry
around in my head.
It's rounded off a little bit,
but I use that number so often
that I carry it around
in my head.
The latent heat of condensation,
or if you like,
the latent heat of
evaporation--
it's the same magnitude,
independent of whether you're
condensing or evaporating
water-- is about 2 and 1/2
million joules per kilogram.
And so when you condense water,
you're then providing
extra heat to the air, which
makes it warmer, more buoyant.
It's likely to rise then, and
that's what's going on in all
of these storms. It's the basic
underlying energy source.
We talked about air-mass
thunderstorms last time and
how they go through
a life cycle.
And after--
they take about 20 minutes to
30 minutes to develop from a
fair-weather cumulus into a
cumulonimbus with rain coming
out the bottom.
And then as the rain begins,
you begin to get some
evaporation of falling
rainwater
just below cloud base.
That produces cool air, which
then sinks and spreads out.
It's like you open your freezer
door, and that cold
air from the freezer falls down
to the kitchen floor and
then spreads out.
That's what's happening, and
that goes by various names.
Sometimes we call it a
downburst. Sometimes it's
called a gust front.
The front of it is called
the gust front.
But anyway, the air is now
spreading out away from the
cloud, and that shuts off
the warm, moist inflow.
So it kills itself
off, basically.
It has a-- after about
two hours, it's gone.
Now, that outflow might well
trigger another thunderstorm.
So that doesn't mean, for
example, over the state of
Connecticut on a day when there
are thunderstorms, it
doesn't mean there's just going
to be one and then none.
It means there'll be one, and
then as it dies, it may
trigger two others, and
then as they die,
they may trigger others.
So this may go on throughout
the afternoon, but the
individual cells have
a short lifetime.
That's an important
characteristic.
As opposed to these severe
storms, which have the
additional environmental factor
of having wind shear
through the troposphere, usually
a jet stream aloft.
Strong winds near the
tropopause, weak winds near
the surface of the Earth, that
tends to bend the storm over
and change its structure into
one in which the inflow is at
a different location than the
outflow caused by that
evaporative cooling.
In fact, the cold air generated
by evaporative
cooling spreads out and actually
forms a gust front
over which the warm
air then lifts.
So it actually assists in the
lifting of the warm air up
into the cloud.
And this structure is more or
less stable and can persist
for a number of hours
and in some cases
even for even overnight.
And these are the
ones that have--
they're larger and
they're severe in
every way you can imagine.
I think I showed these
last time.
But heavy rains and
flooding, hail,
lightning, tornadic winds.
I don't think the low pressure
in the tornado is much of an
issue, but the gust-front winds
coming from that cool
air is another source
of wind damage.
In many-- in some cases, that
causes more damage than even a
tornado could.
Usually, the tornadic winds are
stronger when there is a
tornado, but the gust-front
winds may cover a wider area
and in some cases will
cause more damage
than a possible tornado.
I don't know if I got
this far, but here's
a picture of one.
And earlier in the course, we
talked about the visual
appearance of a funnel.
And this is called the
condensation funnel.
That is basically a cloud
composed of tiny liquid water
droplets that's produced when
air from outside moves in and
drops its pressure.
The pressure inside a tornado
is much lower than in the
surrounding atmosphere, so that
air that moves in there
is going to expand, not by
moving vertically, but by
moving into the tornado.
It'll expand, cool, and
you can form a cloud.
And that's what you're seeing.
In fact, you often see this
descending from cloud base.
The cloud base will appear to
be flat, and then as the
tornado develops, that
funnel cloud will
descend to the ground.
When you see that, it's more
natural to understand that
it's really like a cloud,
because it's actually an
extension of that cloud reaching
down to the surface.
Whereas this other thing here
is the debris funnel.
That's stuff that's been kicked
up by the high winds at
the surface, and that's
not water.
That's usually dirt or soil or
cows or cars or houses and
things like that.
And here again, you see the
condensation funnel, and you
see a debris funnel
around that.
Lightning comes along
with that.
And of course, these sparks of
electricity is what you hear
as thunder.
And I think you know that-- how
many know how to compute
in your mind how
far a storm is?
Do you know that trick?
It's pretty simple, because you
assume that the light that
comes from the lightning strike
travels to your eye at
the speed of light, which
is, you might say,
instantaneous, right?
Whereas the sound that reaches
your ear moves at the speed of
sound, which is something like
300 meters per second.
And so if you simply-- when you
see a lightning flash, if
you then count out the
number of seconds--
one second, two seconds--
so for every second delay
between the two, that's 300
meters of distance.
So if it was three seconds
delayed, that would be 900
meters or about a kilometer
away from you.
So that's an easy calculation
to do, realizing that the
thunder is produced by
the lightning itself.
You suddenly heat that air with
the electrical discharge,
it expands suddenly, produces
an acoustic signal that then
travels to your ear, and you
recognize that as thunder.
Questions on that?
Hailstones, because there's a
lot of supercooled water above
the freezing line in those
storms and very strong updraft
motions that can suspend
particles while
they grow by riming.
And eventually, when either that
updraft weakens or the
object becomes too
large, it'll then
fall out of the sky.
And it's too large to melt.
I told you many times that a
snowflake will melt as it
passes down through
the freezing level
and become a raindrop.
But if I've got a chunk of ice
that's five centimeters across
and it falls down,
it's too big.
It's going to take
minutes to melt.
And by that time, it'll
be at the surface.
It'll be wet, it'll have a wet
outer surface, but it'll still
be a solid chunk of ice when
it falls to Earth and hits.
This is thunderstorm frequency
across the United States,
number of thunderstorms
per year.
Now, I've told you that
these are called--
most of these are just air-mass
thunderstorms.
They're not so damaging.
And it looks like Florida is
the capital for air-mass
thunderstorms. You get
100 of them per year.
Other areas get far less.
But these aren't the
severe ones.
I'll show you the severe
ones in just a moment.
You don't get many thunderstorms
in the West
Coast, because there's too
strong an inversion there.
Theres a temp-- normally, with
the cold water off the coast
from the California Current,
the atmosphere over here is
just too stable, too many
inversions to get
thunderstorms forming in
that part of the world.
So it really is kind of an
East Coast phenomenon.
But it starts right at the Rocky
Mountain Front here in
Colorado, and you find storms
then pretty much all the way
to the east, including all the
way up into Canada you get
quite a few.
Now, I don't often in this
course talk about the research
that goes on here at Yale or in
my group, but I wanted to
show you one thing.
I had a Ph.D. Student who
finished a couple of years ago
who tried to understand the
timing of thunderstorms from
west to east across--
in a region generally
like this.
And so she looked at
a lot of climate--
of rainfall data from the summer
months and came up with
a diagram like this.
Now, I'm going to
explain this.
It's going to take a minute just
to figure out what in the
heck is plotted here.
But on this axis is longitude.
So it's distance east-west
basically through a region
something like this.
So it's the distance east-west
in a latitude belt
something like that.
And on this axis is the
local solar time.
So instead of actually using
time zones, which are kind of
an artificial construct--
they make arbitrary choices
about where to switch from
Eastern Time to Central Time
to Mountain Time--
this is just local time.
Basically, how high is the sun
in the sky, that determines
what this clock would be.
And then contoured is the
precipitation rate, the hourly
precipitation rate.
So from this diagram, for any
given latitude, if you scan
up, you'll find how much
it rains at different
hours of the day.
Now, we did repeat.
We plotted everything twice.
So you've got zero to 24
and then 24 to 48.
But if you notice, the plot
just repeats as well.
So we've just put the same data
on there twice, which
makes it a little bit
easier to go through
a full day's cycle.
You can start at any hour you
want and go 24 hours ahead.
So this is the Rocky
Mountain Front.
This is where a lot of
thunderstorms form.
It's over in here.
And those storms tend to form
between 1200 and 1800.
So that's in the afternoon,
local solar time.
Now, that's not a
surprise, right?
Because one of the most
important triggers for
thunderstorms is the heating
of the Earth by the Sun.
So it's in the afternoon when
you've built up this deep
convective boundary layer
by heating the
surface of the Earth.
And finally, that heating is
going to generate cumulus
clouds, and they'll then grow
to form cumulonimbus.
So it's not surprising
that you find
storms beginning there.
And over the East Coast-- here
in Connecticut, for example--
you also find that the storms
form in the afternoon, due to
the heating of the
Earth by the Sun.
But look what happens in this
middle territory, which is
basically this very large
region through here.
That has some other kind of a
trigger, because, look, that
is advancing in time.
As I move eastward, the time
of day when thunderstorms
occur is 6 o'clock, 9 o'clock
in the evening, midnight, 3
o'clock in the morning,
6 o'clock the next
morning, and so on.
So you've got something that is
departing from the simple
idea of the Sun as the
driving force.
What this turns out to be is a
disturbance that's generated
each day over the Rocky
Mountains and then is--
whoops, wrong direction--
and then is pushed eastwards
by the westerly winds.
And it's a warm air disturbance
generated over the mountains.
And as it drifts eastward
aloft, it triggers
thunderstorms as
it moves along.
I had somebody in my office
a couple of weeks ago, a
scientist who grew up in one
of these states and always
wondered why there they had a
maximum thunderstorm frequency
in the middle of the night.
Who would expect that?
It doesn't seem to fit with
the standard thermal solar
forcing idea.
Well, this is why.
In this case, my student
discovered that it's a
disturbance generated over the
Rockies that moves eastward
and gives that progressive
timing to the thunderstorms.
Then you get east of the
Appalachian Mountains, and you
get back to a more normal
mid-afternoon
thunderstorm maxima.
Any questions on that?
STUDENT: What are those
dotted lines?
PROFESSOR: I think
they're reference lines
for some other figure in the
paper that's not shown here.
So there are sloping lines
that are drawn in here at
different speeds.
Since this is distance versus
time, a slope represents a
propagation speed--
30 meters per second, 14 meters
per second, seven
meters per second.
These disturbances move eastward
at about 14 meters
per second, bringing those
thunderstorms progressively
later as you move
towards the east. Yes.
STUDENT: Was it already known
that there was a warm weather
air disturbance over
the Rockies, or did
she figure that out?
PROFESSOR: No, that's not shown in this
figure, but that
was actually--
there was some hint about this
progression already from radar
data, but she confirmed
it using surface data.
And then she discovered this
warm air pulse aloft that was
doing the triggering.
That was the point of
her thesis, yeah.
Anything else on that?
So now let's get to the severe
thunderstorms. And the way
I'll get at that is just to
show you this tornado
frequency map.
And of course, it looks
a bit different.
There is a maximum in Florida,
but it's smaller.
And the big maximum
is over Texas,
Oklahoma, Kansas, Nebraska.
And of course, this is
what's called Tornado
Alley by some people.
You've heard that expression.
It's kind of the region.
But what's special about this
region apparently-- and by the
way, this maximizes
in the spring.
So typically, this is an
April-May phenomenon.
If you have watched any of
these shows about chasing
tornadoes and if you want to
do that, then schedule your
trip in April and May, because
that's when things get
exciting out there.
And what's special about this
region is that you get some
warm, moist air moving in from
the Gulf of Mexico at low
levels, and then you get the jet
stream coming across the
Rocky Mountains at
high levels.
And that gives you the
shear that you need.
And you've got the moisture,
because you've got the high
temperatures and high humidities
in the low levels.
So all the ingredients
are kind of there.
Not every day-- it fluctuates
from day to day-- but
generally, that's the reason why
this area is so special.
And as far as I know, there's
no other place on Earth that
has as many-- as high a tornado
frequency as this
region does.
So this is special even
if you look globally.
There are a few other places in
Asia and in Australia where
they get this phenomenon, but
this is kind of the most
frequent place for
it to occur.
Questions there?
Anybody from Tornado Alley?
Anybody live in these states?
Not at all?
You're all East Coast or
West Coast people?
Yeah.
STUDENT: The little spots in the
Southeast, is there-- is
that a coincidence?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's a good question.
For example, I read a paper once
about this one, who tried
to claim there was something
special about the terrain in
that region.
But to be honest with you, I
would doubt the statistical
significance of something like
that, unless I really had seen
a very rigorous statistical
analysis.
I would wonder whether these
spots are really realistic or
whether they're just a fluke
of what-- and he had one or
two events there, and by random
chance, that happened
to look like a little maximum
or something like that.
So I wouldn't try to put too
much significance on those.
Whether that-- that may be
distinct from this one.
I think the case could
be made there.
But I'm not sure why.
I'm not sure why there would
be two maxima there.
We do get them in Connecticut
as well.
Not frequently, but every few
years, we get a tornado that
comes down through the state.
It can cause quite
a bit of damage.
But it's like a ratio of 7:1
or 9:1 in terms of the
relative frequency of
those two things.
So before we leave the subject,
I want to give you a
little bit of a sense for
what a tornado is like.
And here's a picture from May
2007, the devastation in
Greensburg, Kansas.
Really a whole town was--
isn't that horrible?
It's just everything
wiped out.
And the only way I could think
of-- and this is going to take
a couple minutes and may be a
little bit boring-- we'll
see-- but I want to show you
what the news was saying at
this point.
So this is--
this is the radar, the
Doppler radar--
I'll explain why that's
important in just a minute--
blue-red.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So keep in mind, as far
as looking through the
thunderstorm and seeing the
tornado appear in Greensburg,
you're not going to, because
it's going to be obscured by
the very heavy rain and also the
hail between you and that
circulation.
Greenburg's up here at the
top of the screen.
-And when we switch
over to the
which-way-the-wind's-blowing
mode to the
how-hard-it's-raining mode,
this is what we have now.
And you can see that very
high reflectivity.
What you see is that red.
That is the heavy
rain and hail.
So you're not going to be able
to visualize the thunderstorm
if it's still producing
a tornado.
-Now, contact with Lanny Dean,
we temporarily lost it because
of the cell service in this
part of Kansas, but once
again, you're seeing a very
strong, very well-pronounced
hook echo in addition to the
very strong velocity returns--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: That's
the hook echo right there.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The city of Greensburg and to
the south, I really suggest
you go down to your
storm shelters.
I said I'm not an alarmist kind
of guy, but if the only
thing-- this storm
is very scary--
in the worst case, I'm just
going to waste a little bit of
your time tonight if you go down
to your shelters and it
turns out not to be producing
a tornado.
But just what we're
seeing here is
a very scary signature.
-Lanny, how close are you
to the county line?
-We have passed the county
line already, Jay.
-So you're north of the county
line, and the tornado, from
your vantage point, is to the
east of US 183, correct?
-Jay, a very large tornado.
OK, I don't know who reported
it in the west. We have two
tornadoes on the ground, Jay.
We have a small-- well, excuse
me it's a medium, if you will,
to my north-northeast. We have
a very large wedge tornado on
the ground that's going
to be almost
due north of my location.
I'm going to put it about five
miles, Jay, about five miles,
I'm guessing, north, maybe five
to eight miles north of
my location right now, Jay.
-All right, Landy, try
to get the first cam
fired up if you can.
And now let's go
over to Darren.
And, Darren, what do you see
from your vantage point?
-Right now, we're just about
ready to get on the Highway
183 to go north towards
Greensburg.
We still have a large wedge
tornado on the ground to our
north with possible satellite
tornadoes.
We just saw a lightning flash
that still probably--
I would say probably five miles
to our north is where
the tornado would be located.
And it has been on the ground
for probably 25 minutes, maybe
even longer.
[END VIDEO PLAYBCK]
PROFESSOR: It's moving in that direction.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-What cross-street?
How far north of the
Kiowa-Comanche
county line are you?
-We're right on the line.
-You're right on the
line currently.
And you're about to
proceed northbound
back behind the tornado?
-That's correct.
-And you've been watching this
for quite a little while.
And what did you estimate
its maximum width was?
-I would say easily a mile,
and that's kind of being
conservative.
Before that, we had two separate
mesocyclones with--
it looked to be a cone tornado,
and then off to our
east probably a quarter to a
half mile was a stovepipe
tornado, a lot of power
flashes with it.
-All right, Darren.
And I know you've--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: I'm going to stop
that there for a minute.
Well, I guess I'll stop
it there anyway.
But there are two things I
wanted to point out to you.
So he's got two things
he's looking at.
He's got the radar, and he's
looking at the reflectivity,
which is telling you where
the rain is falling.
And in that, he's finding
this shape, which is
called the hook echo.
So there's rain falling through
here, and the spin up
in the cloud is wrapping
this rain shaft around
in a kind of spiral.
And that's a very clear
signature of a very strong
cyclone aloft.
Then he's also got
the Doppler.
For the same instrument, the
same radar, it measures the
frequency of the reflected
radar beam.
And they know what frequency
they sent out.
If it comes back a higher
frequency, that means the air
at that location is moving
towards you.
If it comes back at a lower
frequency, it's
moving away from you.
This is the Doppler effect.
When a car goes by or a train
goes by, you hear that
[ZOOMING NOISE]
as it's coming towards you and
then going away from you.
There's that frequency shift.
And what he was showing with
these two regions, one was red
and one was blue, indicating in
one region the wind is away
from you, in the other region
it's toward you.
So it probably was like this
if the radar was down here,
which means there
is a cyclone.
On this side its--you're not
measuring this other component.
You're just measuring the
component towards and away
from the radar.
But when you see that doublet,
that velocity away from you
and velocity towards you,
there's really only one
explanation for that.
There's a tight vortex right in
there up in the cloud, and
very possibly that's causing
a tornado at the ground.
So what's nice about that
film loop is that's
not after the fact.
That's during the fact.
So he's putting himself on the
line and saying, listen, I
know sometimes we have false
alarms about these things, but
this is one of the strongest
signatures I've ever seen.
So he's putting out that kind
of warning to the people.
It's pretty-- it takes some
guts to do that, because
occasionally they do
get this wrong.
So we're going to continue,
and I think that's--
yeah, so that's all we have on
severe thunderstorms. Are
there any questions on severe
thunderstorms before we go on
to another subject?
So you can read about
it in this book.
It's fascinating stuff.
And we'll turn to hurricanes.
Now, a few basic bullet points
about hurricanes.
As with other convective storms,
they get their energy
from latent heat release.
In this case, they get
that water vapor
directly from the ocean.
So it doesn't-- you don't use
up the water vapor in the
atmosphere as a tornado begins
to draw on it, because with a
warm ocean, you can evaporate
water from the ocean just as
fast as you're drawing
it up in the storm.
So in one way, it's better to
say that really it's the warm
ocean that provides the fuel
for this, but yet it's also
water vapor.
The warm water evaporates, and
then you get the water vapor
that goes up into the cloud.
And as it rises, you get the
latent heat release and the
buoyancy and so on
and so forth.
Now, if you have too
much wind shear--
this is just the opposite of
the severe thunderstorm.
Severe thunderstorms require
that wind shear to distort it
and give it that severe
condition, whereas hurricanes
out over the ocean, if you have
a lot of wind shear, they
will not form.
They're a symmetric kind of
deal, and if you try to shear
that off, you'll just
destroy it.
So you need a lot of warm ocean
water and not very much
shear, and then you can, under
some conditions, you can
generate a hurricane.
They cannot form at the Equator,
because they have to
spin one way or the other, and
they get that cue from the
Coriolis force.
And so if there's no
Coriolis force, you
cannot form a hurricane.
So they cannot form
at the Equator.
And as I mentioned the other
day, they cannot even cross
the Equator.
Once they've formed in one
hemisphere, they've got to
stay in that hemisphere.
They can't suddenly decide to
wander across to the other
hemisphere.
They couldn't exist with the
spin that they have. They do
spin oppositely in the
two hemispheres.
Just like in the tornado, the
pressure is very low in the
center, and that balances the
Coriolis force and the
centripetal force of the air
spinning around the outside.
So this is a cyclone in the
same sense that I defined
cyclone for you the other day.
It's a low-pressure center
with air currents moving
around it in a cyclonic
direction--
that is, counterclockwise in
the Northern Hemisphere,
clockwise in the Southern
Hemisphere.
They occur in the late summer
and early fall in both
hemispheres.
Be careful how you use those
terms. On land, the highest
temperatures normally occur four
to six weeks after the
summer solstice.
The summer solstice
is about June 21.
The warmest days of summer are
usually mid-July for air over
the continents.
But oceans have more heat
capacity, and they take a
longer time to warm up.
So the warmer ocean temperatures
occur almost
three months after the
summer solstice.
The warmest ocean temperatures
typically are in August,
September, and October.
And since the hurricanes need
that, they need warm ocean
temperatures, the hurricane
season is then delayed that
three months.
So it's not midsummer
or early summer.
It's late summer and early fall,
because that's when the
ocean's sea surface
temperature--
SST is the abbreviation for
sea surface temperature--
is the highest. That
defines the
so-called hurricane season.
Now remember, in the Northern
Hemisphere, that is going to
be July, August, September,
and maybe a little bit in
October, whereas in the Southern
Hemisphere, that is
going to be, well, January,
February, March, and April in
the Southern Hemisphere.
That's their summertime, and
that's when hurricanes are
going to be most frequent in
the Southern Hemisphere.
They tend to drift westward,
because they occur in the
tropics under the influence
of the trade winds.
It's like you had a stream of
water and you dip your hand in
and made a little vortex, and
you would watch and see that
that vortex is just carried
along by the stream.
Whatever direction the stream is
going in, that vortex would
move as well.
And that's primarily what's
going on when tornado is--
when a hurricane is
moving westward.
However, it also has a poleward
drift that can't be
explained as simply as that, and
that has something to do
with the curvature
of the Earth.
I've published on this,
but I don't have time
to go through it.
But there is a drift of
hurricanes toward the pole in
both hemispheres--
the North Pole in the Northern
Hemisphere, the South Pole in
the Southern Hemisphere--
that is added to that general
westward drift due to being in
the belt of the easterly
trade winds.
So these are the global
hurricane tracks.
It's interesting for what is in
this diagram and what's not
in this diagram.
For example, in the North
Atlantic Ocean--
the Equator is about here--
generally, hurricanes form in
the central and sometimes even
eastern part of the tropical
North Atlantic, and then they
move westward and northward.
So generally, they follow a
looping trajectory like this,
or maybe they go straight into
the Gulf of Mexico or through
the Caribbean into the Gulf
of Mexico like that.
In the eastern tropical North
Pacific, you have a very high
density of hurricanes.
Most of these don't threaten
land, because they're going
out to sea, but some of them
that move up along the coast
can threaten land.
They don't go very far north,
because there's a cold
California Current that
comes down here.
I didn't put this in the notes,
but you should write it
down that many people think
there's a critical ocean
temperature below which you
cannot have hurricanes.
And some people will tell you
that's 27 degrees Celsius.
Some people say it's
28 degrees Celsius.
But somewhere about there is a
critical ocean temperature.
And so the ocean has to be
warmer than, let's say, 28
Celsius before it can
support a hurricane.
And you don't have that up
here, because the cold
California Current comes
down, but closer to
the Equator you do.
Notice, right at the Equator,
no hurricanes.
Plenty of warm water, but
no Coriolis force, so no
hurricanes.
The western tropical North
Pacific is a hotbed-- the
world's biggest hotbed
of hurricanes.
Be careful, though.
The word "hurricane"
traditionally is not used in
that part of the world.
These are normally referred to
as typhoons, after a Japanese
word for "hurricane." So it
wouldn't be wrong to call
these hurricanes, but it
wouldn't be the vernacular.
The vernacular would
be typhoon.
And so if I say there's a
typhoon in the Western
Pacific, you'll know
I'm talking
about a hurricane there.
And they've got the same kind of
pattern as in the Atlantic.
They go westward, but they
also arc northwards.
In the Indian Ocean, you get
some in the Arabian Sea and
the Bay of Bengal.
Not many, but you do
get some, and they
can be quite damaging.
In the Southern Hemisphere,
look at this.
You get them in the
Indian Ocean.
You get them in the west
tropical Pacific.
You don't get them in
the east at all.
And I would've said you don't
get them in the Atlantic, but
there was one about
four years ago.
It was the first-ever reported
hurricane in the tropical
South Pacific, and they've got
that one marked in here.
Now, this is pretty
easy to explain.
There's a cold current--
it's called the Humboldt
Current,
after a German explorer--
a cold current that comes up
along the coast of South
America and floods this part
of the southern eastward
tropical Pacific.
And therefore, the temperatures
are not warm
enough to support hurricanes.
And pretty much the same
thing is true here.
There's a cold current that
comes up along here.
And while there is some warm air
right-- some water right
along the Equator, there you
don't have the Coriolis force.
And here you've got the Coriolis
force, but the
temperatures are too low.
So you're not getting those two
ingredients together, the
warm water and the
Coriolis force.
Questions on this diagram?
Remember, these are not
occurring simultaneously.
This is in Northern Hemisphere
hurricane season.
These are in Southern Hemisphere
We've just put them all together
on one diagram there.
So here's a zoom in of
the Atlantic Ocean.
And you can see that
many of them come--
so once a hurricane gets
started, it's going to
persist. It's a good,
stable storm system.
It'll persist until
the conditions no
longer make it possible.
One of two things will happen.
It'll move over land, in which
case it no longer has that
water supply, or it'll move over
cold water, in which case
it no longer has enough
water supply.
Because the water can't
evaporate fast enough from a
cold ocean.
Typically, from the satellite,
they look like this.
They have a well-developed,
large cloud shield.
It's like a thunderstorm anvil,
except it's kind of
axisymmetric.
That means moving out
in all directions.
And very often, but not always,
there's an eye, which
is a very peculiar
characteristic.
The air everywhere else is
rising, but right there, the
air is sinking.
I know that because it's
clear of clouds.
Clear of clouds means sinking
air, thermodynamically.
Underneath this, you can't see
it, but the winds are strong
in the cyclonic direction.
So here's kind of a cartoonish
cross-section.
You've got these rain bands.
The rain is not uniform in a
hurricane but forms in these
spiral, heavy-raining bands.
The air rises in this main
eyewall and then spreads out
in this giant anvil.
First, it's still moving in
the cyclonic direction.
When that air moves far enough
out, the Coriolis force acts
on it and actually reverses
its sense of direction.
So be careful.
If you're looking at movies of
hurricanes, you may find that
the outer clouds are actually
moving anticyclonically.
Don't be confused.
All the rest of the storm is
still a tight, cyclonically
spinning vortex.
And then a little bit of that
air that rises in the eyewall
sinks right down in the eye and
keeps that little section
clear of clouds.
Most of it, however, spreads out
in this giant anvil, whose
diameter is several hundred
kilometers across.
So hurricane damage, of
course, wind impact on
buildings and vegetation.
Remember that the pressure
that a wind exerts on a
surface is proportional to the
square of the wind speed.
So if you have a 10 meter per
second wind hitting my house,
that produces a certain force.
If you have a 20 meters per
second, that's four times--
twice the speed, but four
times the pressure force
pushing on the house,
and so on.
So if you have a hurricane
that's 60 meters per second or
120 meters per second, the
destructive forces of that
push really go up very, very
steeply and can destroy most
buildings, unless they're
specially designed to be
hurricane-secure.
Another thing is that
storm surge.
The rapid air movement across
the surface of the ocean
pushes water towards the shore
and will give an apparent rise
in sea level.
We talked about this when we
were discussing Irene.
And if you're standing on the
beach, the water just suddenly
seems to rise and move inland.
On top of that, there's going to
be the waves caused by the
winds as well, but that storm
surge is often responsible for
some of the major damage.
Inland flooding as well, and
we saw that in Irene.
Poor Vermont, and New Jersey to
some extent too, had a lot
of rainfall, which collected
quickly into the valleys and
rivers and caused a
lot of flooding.
Of course, for many people here
in Connecticut, the main
impact of Hurricane Irene
was losing their
electrical power for days.
And that's mostly in this part
of the world, because the wind
will take down a tree limb and
wipe out most-- in this
country, most of our power
lines are above ground.
It's cheaper to do that, easy to
maintain in most cases, but
they're so vulnerable
to tipping trees.
So when you got a high wind
event like this, trees come
down, hit the wires.
You lose both communication
and power.
In other parts of the world,
hurricanes are often followed
a few weeks later by enormous
loss of life from disease.
For example, if you have a
hurricane hitting Bangladesh
or some of the other undeveloped
countries, what
you'll have--
the hurricane will be finished
and it'll be
long gone, and then--
but people will be displaced
from their homes.
And more importantly, water
sources get mixed.
So sewage gets into drinking
water typically, and then
disease begins.
And in the weeks and months that
follow, you could have
hundreds, thousands, even tens
of thousands of deaths arising
from the, quote, "hurricane,"
but it really has to do with
just contamination of water
supplies and a lack of a
public health service to be sure
that that sort of thing
doesn't happen.
So this is the biggest loss of
life from hurricanes by far,
but these other things are
important as well.
Any questions on that?
So the most famous hurricane in
New England was nicknamed
the Long Island Express
in 1938.
It had a track like this and
hit Connecticut directly.
A lot of damage along the
Connecticut coast, even more
along the Rhode Island coast.
The hurricane produces its
biggest damage on the right
front quadrant.
So it's got four quadrants
based on how it's moving.
It's that right front quadrant
that tends to have the
strongest winds and in many
cases the heaviest
precipitation.
And in this case, that hit Rhode
Island and caused a lot
of damage there.
If you Google "hurricane, 1938,"
that one will pop up,
and you can read all about it.
It really was a major event
and is still talked about
today in Connecticut.
We had our own chance at this
just a few weeks ago.
Hurricane Irene had a track
similar to that but not
exactly the same.
The difference probably was that
it brushed ashore here
near Cape Hatteras and lost a
lot of its strength before it
hit New England, partly by its
lack of water vapor over the
land and also the frictional--
with all the trees and so on
over land, that friction
weakened it.
So by the time it hit us, it had
weakened to a Category 2
or perhaps even 1.
And it still caused a lot of
flooding damage but not so
much wind damage and
other things.
And then of course, the most
damaging hurricane in our
country's history was
Hurricane Katrina
in August of 2005.
And it had a different track.
It started here in
the eastern--
well, just north of Cuba,
crossed over the southern tip
of Florida, regained
its strength, and
then hit New Orleans.
And you can read all about
that in the history books
now-- in history
books now too.
And there's a picture of Katrina
just as it was about
to hit New Orleans, a
beautifully formed storm with
a beautiful central eye
and the cloud shield
and the whole business.
Very strong storm that
hit New Orleans.
This is what I mentioned
before.
There's a well-defined
hurricane season.
And here it is for Atlantic
hurricanes.
And of course, when I say
"Atlantic," I'm referring to
North Atlantic.
Because, remember, there are
no hurricanes in the South
Atlantic, so this is the
Northern Hemisphere hurricane
frequencies for the
Atlantic Ocean.
And typically, the frequency
is non-negligible even in
June, but it begins to rise
quickly at the first of
August, peaks in early,
mid-September, and then you're
kind of out of the woods by
the time you get to the
beginning or the middle
of November.
And this all has to do with
ocean surface temperatures.
Questions on that?
Yes.
Well, it is-- we have five
minutes to go, but rather than
starting a new subject, why
don't we call it quits today?
And we'll do mid-latitude
frontal cyclones on Friday.